just days before Christmas Mrs Claus
makes a miraculous rescue that some are
calling divine intervention can you hand
me your hands come on it happened on
Monday in Fredericksburg Virginia
Lieutenant team Merrill was on her way
home from a public safety Santa run
where she dressed as Mrs Claus when she
passed the Falmouth Bridge she noticed a
woman leaning over the side
still dressed in her Mrs Claus dress
glasses and wig Lieutenant Merrell
approached the woman and began using
Crisis Intervention skills we thought
you you're fine okay we've got you also
driving home Patrol Sergeant a Lynch saw
what was happening and pulled over his
body camera footage caught the heroic
act on camera
together the off-duty officers helped
the 25 year old woman to safety she was
later Taken to a nearby hospital to
receive mental health treatment
in a statement on the Frederickburg
Police Department's Facebook page Chief
Layton wrote in part quote the most
amazing part of this story is that
Lieutenant Merrell and Sergeant Lynch
typically take a different route home
call it divine intervention or fate I
truly believe these officers were meant
to take the route they did and help save
This Woman's life for the latest
developments in this story and all
things True Crime stay with long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie